Three years ago, we organized a Nexus conference
entitled 'The Triumph of Science', and we
also had people from the world of transhumanism.
I was fascinated by the fact that, based on
a pretty pessimistic view of human nature,
they think that, with the technology we have,
we should improve human beings with this technology,
because the world is too dangerous.
There are, indeed, nuclear weapons, and to
make sure that tragedies do not happen we
should use new technologies to improve human
nature.
What do you think about that?
I'm very sceptical.
First of all, I am sceptical that we need
to re-engineer humans to achieve peace.
Canada and the United States have not fought
a war since the War of 1812, and no one had
to re-engineer Canadians or Americans.
The Netherlands and Germany have not fought
a war in more than 70 years.
We did not have to genetically engineer the
Dutch.
There are many changes to our institutions
and our norms and our ideas that can reduce
or eliminate the risks of nuclear war, without
what I consider a rather quixotic attempt
to change the course of human evolution.
Also on purely scientific grounds, I'm highly
sceptical of the prophesy that we will re-engineer
human nature.
I think that these predictions came during
the brief burst of enthusiasm for finding
the gene for intelligence, the gene for altruism
and so on.
We now know that there is no such gene; there
are hundreds or thousands of genes, each of
which increments or decrements psychological
traits by a tiny amount.
To genetically engineer someone it's not a
matter of sticking in one gene, you'd have
to replace thousands of genes.
We have no idea how to do that; we're not
going to know how to do that any time soon,
and we also don't know how many of those genes
might lead to an improvement in one aspect
and a risk in another aspect.
There may be a gene that increases your IQ
by two-thirds of a point, but also increases
your chances of getting brain cancer, or bipolar
disorder by a third of a point.
It's going to be a very long time, if ever,
until we know how to balance those tiny benefits
and tiny risks, multiplied by hundreds or
thousands of genes.
So on purely scientific grounds, I doubt that
it will happen, and on historical grounds,
I don't think we need it.
What will be your choice, what is it that
you think is essential to make sure that,
in whatever form 'we can save the world'?
First of all, we have to have an empirical
mindset.
You are right: there are many hypotheses,
we have to look which ones have made the world
better and which have made the world worse.
I think the track record of messiahs is not
particularly good.
I think there is excellent reason to believe
that there is no such thing as a messiah,
and there never will be.
On the other hand, there are some things that
do work: international institutions like the
United Nations have decreased the probability
of war, it hasn't eliminated war but it has
made it less likely.
We have reason to believe that trade and cosmopolitanism,
the movement of people and ideas, has been
a positive force.
We have reason to think that democracy has
more advantages than disadvantages, and I
think that what we have to do is not believe
that we can deduce what will make the world
better from first principles, and then impose
them in full confidence that we know how the
world is going to react.
Because we don't; we're not that smart.
But we really have to look at our past track
record.
Look at the data: what makes people better
off, what makes people worse off?
The conference will be the weekend after the
American elections.
Will you still say the same things if Mr.
Trump will be the next president of America?
I think it is extremely unlikely, and all
the indicators are that he will not be the
next president.
If he is president, I think that would definitely
be a negative development, and there is no
guarantee that all positive trends, such as
the trend towards tolerance, cosmopolitanism,
democracy and knowledge-guided decision making
will continue.
There are no iron laws that propel the world
in a particular direction.
There are contingent events that are unpredictable,
so bad things could happen.
How bad could it be if Trump were elected?
Much depends on how much a single man can
control the entire apparatus of American government.
Fortunately, American government has some
checks and balances built in; there's the
Supreme Court, there's the legislatures, there's
local governments and state governments, and
the willingness or reluctance of the American
people to go along with a particular policy.
So as long as Trump doesn't become the Führer,
or like Mao, with absolute control, and I
think that's unlikely, then the worst-case
scenarios probably will not happen.
But then, Trump being elected is itself a
worst-case scenario, that I think will probably
not happen.